these are pictures nobody wanted to see
in bavaria germany covid 19 patients are
being transferred from one hospital to
others because there's not enough
capacity to treat them
beds in intensive care units are getting
sparse
[Music]
for us the situation is very tense all
the beds are full we're still trying to
take care of the urgent cases as best we
can
germany's infection rate has risen to
its highest level since the start of the
pandemic while vaccination rates are at
almost 70 percent of the population
the country that so far has done
relatively better than its neighbors in
dealing with kovid 19 is losing control
what went wrong
[Music]
welcome to our covered 19 special i'm
monica jones and berlin good to have you
with us
thirty thousand
643 that's how many new cases are
reported in germany in the last 24 hours
pushing the infection rate to a new
record high of over 386
and with no sign that the exponential
growth could weaken anytime soon this
week we want to put the spotlight on
germany's pandemic response and its
shocking transformation from role model
to problem case
it was a huge shock when 16 residents at
this care facility for the elderly in
brandenburg died from covid19 despite
having been fully vaccinated
the case made headlines nationwide
because about half of the facility's
staff had not had the jab
it naturally made everyone very sad to
hear that it came from the nursing staff
of course once again it makes you aware
that all people in particular are
dependent on care workers
germany is currently discussing making
vaccination compulsory and not only for
nursing staff
i work in the field of medicine and i
can't understand when people with
medical training are opposed to it it's
incomprehensible to me
they're in constant contact with the
outside world and they could carry the
infection into the home with them
without wanting to and without knowing
it inside men
vaccination rates across germany are
well below target but even if people
want to be vaccinated it's often
difficult to make an appointment
here in bernal north of berlin there is
a pop-up vaccination center once a week
in the town hall people queue for hours
to get vaccinated most want a booster
shot
it's annoying that vaccination centers
were shut down just over a month ago
then shortly afterwards they announced
that they wanted to vaccinate several
million people within a short space of
time
it's annoying but we'll still do
everything we can to vaccinate as many
people as possible but that will only
work hand in hand with local doctors
some doctors have stopped offering the
jab the government has increased the fee
a doctor gets for administering the
vaccine to take the pressure off
vaccination centers
the vaccination drive is a disaster
we've been standing here for over an
hour and we still have a long way to go
it's very difficult to get an
appointment here it really makes you
angry
many local politicians are also angry
they're having to deal with vaccination
chaos on their doorsteps
unlike in many other countries germany
has plenty of vaccines to go around
just too few people who are vaccinated
to stop a fourth wave
and for more on this topic let's bring
in hail sabe he's a professor of
epidemiology and he joins us in bremen
good to have you with us professor sabe
first of all what's your assessment
of the situation in germany how serious
is it from an epidemiologist's point of
view
no it's really very serious because
we we have a steep rising cases we have
steep rising cases also in the hospital
in the intensive care units and uh
there is a little sign of this uh
increase uh stopping at this point in
time so i mean we are looking into
really a very tough winter now
well that we hear a lot also from
politicians german politicians uh but
also keep talking about we have to break
the fourth wave is that still possible
it's uh i mean the waves always uh await
at some time so we will at some stage
see the case numbers decline um yeah
even naturally but but really actively
breaking um is is very tough we have to
do a lot of things now in any case but
that will only very slowly break break
this wave if we may call it so the the
case numbers will go down but
it will take time when we say we have to
do a lot of things apart from increasing
the vaccination rate what else can we do
what else must we do now
yeah it's clearly so that this issue of
reducing contacts again is on the agenda
very much so
it may be called lockdown it may be
called whatever you want but
it simply saw that i mean contacts are
the the main uh
game that we really have to to stop
playing right now we have to reduce the
context substantially now because that
works we'll also have to obviously uh
use again those those rules of your mask
wearing and so on much more strictly
than we have been but the contact issue
is really the main thing especially in
those areas where we have this very high
you know incidence
numbers that we've been seeing in the
particular in southern and uh southeast
germany this is important and has to be
done now
and of course it's interesting to see
that countries like italy or spain that
were really really badly hit during the
first the second wave of this pandemic
are now doing so much better because
they have a much higher vaccination rate
how big a difference would have made for
germany for our situation now if more
people
got vaccinated
well a vaccination is certainly one of
the main players or even the main issue
really now but um it's it's uh
really so that you have to have really
very high vaccination rates so only
vaccination rate is
is not
entirely sufficient
we see in countries like the netherlands
and others that have really good
vaccinations above 80 but they still
have problems so you need to still keep
uh you know a clear head in terms of you
know being careful and not opening up
everything
otherwise
you do run into problems so high
vaccination is important and we have to
strive for it but also be careful with
the measures especially in this quarter
winter times is is very important
of course we very often see
a
yeah a very tricky combination of of
people refusing to get vaccinated
they're also the same people who refuse
to wear a mask or to keep a distance
what needs to be done to convince them
otherwise
yes um i mean there is there's quite a
number of people who
have these misconceptions about what's
going on that they are sort of
too healthy to get affected by this that
um there's this uh that there may be
things that they don't really believe
are true and so forth so there's still
some work to be done to inform people
very well also about the
non-existing risks of the vaccinations
which they sometimes think they are
still out there like long-term effects
of vaccinations and so forth but one
also has to acknowledge that there is a
certain
minority that will not be reached by by
any you know further information that is
also clear but this may not be um the
majority of those who are not uh you
know i haven't got the vaccination so
there's still work to be done to get
those people to get vaccinated
and for others then this discussion is
up there of compulsory vaccination in
the in the midterm right and that
discussion of course is going on now
from as an epidemiologist you also keep
an eye on what happens in other parts of
the world is this what we're seeing
right now a german problem because we
see similar uh reluctance to get
vaccinated in austria german speaking in
german speaking switzerland and of
course here in our own country
yeah it's it's uh i it's certainly not
only uh germany and there are even
countries where there is a much more
trouble in terms of getting people you
know convinced to get vaccinated in in
some countries in eastern europe and so
forth but i mean you mentioned the
german-speaking countries it seems like
there's a certain you know percentage of
the population that just
um have a very strong sort of
idea of of
their their
liberal approach to to things that they
don't want to get uh under pressure and
if the state says or you know
authorities say get vaccinated that's
the reflex is to say no i i i don't want
you know and i will not choose that okay
that's happening i think in most of
these countries okay well professor how
you at
epidemiologist in bremen thank you so
much
cheers welcome
still undecided about taking that
vaccine well here's derek williams with
another viewer question
i read an article implying that
infections can run high regardless of
vaccination levels in a population can
you explain that my guess is the article
that you're talking about referred at
some point to a study submitted by a
harvard researcher that was published
back in september
in the european journal of epidemiology
its title
is quite striking
increases in covet 19 are unrelated to
levels of vaccination across
68 countries and 2 947 counties in the
united states
which of course
makes it sound like the paper is
claiming that vaccines are having no
effect
on the course of the pandemic
anti-vaxx figures and websites rushed to
use it to to push their agendas and it
caused something of an uproar
the thing is
experts say that any claims the study
shows vaccines are useless
failed to take a lot of key factors into
account a big problem they say is that
even though at first glance
vaccine coverage numbers and numbers of
infections
look like they should be directly
correlated it's a lot more complicated
than that beneath the surface
any attempt to establish a correlation
or a lack of it has to consider
what are called
confounding effects those are factors
that
if they aren't taken into account can
twist
or distort
epidemiological results there are many
of them that can influence evaluations
like this
that weren't taken into account at all
in this paper a big one
is that even in highly vaccinated
societies
significant numbers of people
remain unvaccinated it's pretty
complicated stuff and you can spend
hours on it but but maybe it's enough to
know
that the lead author has since said that
attempts to use his report to imply that
vaccines are useless
are misleading and inaccurate
you